well Congress returns to work next week
and there is already talk about a
multi-billion dollar disaster relief
bill and questions about how it will be
funded CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe
is a congressional reporter for The
Washington Post and he joins us now from
Washington ed good morning Congress
already had a really long to-do list a
very short timeline to get it done
is this funding bill going to happen
it's gonna have to happen and it adds to
a really long to-do list in fact parts
of the response that's underway were
factored into what Congress has to do
for example the National Flood Insurance
Program which is going to get tapped
pretty mightily here in the coming weeks
has to be reauthorized and basically
reorganized by the end of September
they're gonna have to come up with
billions of dollars for the disaster
relief fund that's overseen by FEMA
there's only about two billion dollars
available in it right now several
billions more likely to be needed I was
speaking with some Texas lawmakers
yesterday who said they've started doing
the math they're gonna have to wait
obviously until the storm passes and the
damage is assessed but they anticipate
it will go into the multi billions of
dollars both Republican senators voted
no when it came time for a relief bill
for superstorm sandy how do you think
that that will play out this time you
know I've heard I've heard Ted Cruz say
listen this is not the time for
political sniping right and it wasn't
back then either but he certainly did
and look already a lot of lawmakers from
the Northeast who suffered after
superstorm sandy and had to wait more
than 60 days for Congress to pony up the
money have said look we acknowledge and
we're aware of the hypocrisy that
potentially may play out here in the
coming weeks from a lot of Republican
lawmakers especially from the south who
voted against our aid package and now
we're going to need it we're not going
to hold that against them we're gonna
support it but they're certainly gonna
get called out for it and the last time
sorry they also insisted on cuts to
offset the funding for Sandy are they're
gonna do that this time as well well the
irony with that Maurice is that there
isn't much more that the federal
government can cut at this point a lot
of agencies including some that are
going to have roles to play in the
coming weeks here are down to their bare
bones so it may be now a situation where
fiscal conservatives the ones that are
the ones that usually raise these
concerns are just gonna have to hold
their nose and
vote for this and let the government
slip into a little more debt and do you
think that because of this long laundry
list this in some ways ties the hands of
the president in the next few days I
mean he was supposed to be rolling out
tax reform there was also this
expectation he was going to unveil his
policy on how to deal with dreamers
those people who came her as children
illegally and what their status is now I
think a lot of this has to get pushed
back by sheer reality that they're gonna
need the days they're gonna need the
time and the focus to be on this massive
emergency relief bill tax reform look
they've been talking about it for years
they still don't have a plan what's a
few more weeks of them planning to do
something later in the fall or next year
I think what'll be most interesting
Margaret is whether he continues to
insist on money for the border wall that
he wants and whether that still
threatens the potential shutdown at the
end of September I don't know that
Americans will be tolerable will
tolerate that frankly if so much of
Texas Louisiana and other areas of the
country need this relief from Harvey and
he's heading there today to see for
himself thank you very much I'd be very
interesting to see how it plays out
that'll keep thank you